welcome back bayside
i can't wait to start junior year last
year you changed this place i got people
to care about important stuff not just
baseline nonsense hey dad think fast
this is gonna be awesome
oh boy here we go oh really
bayside is hosting the california school
spirit competition oh really
it's the perfect venue for our second
kiss
hey what a delicious sight to told me
you're not a part of this spencer hello
as many of you know bayside has a bitter
rivalry with valley our rivals just
destroyed our mascot
take me instead god make the switch you
cowards let's go
okay people i have a big agenda so we
need to stop getting distracted yeah i
know you're looking to know you're
looking at me
having a crush on someone is
embarrassing and distracting you're good
for me like broccoli
what oh yeah i know you look and know
you're looking at me jesse what's wrong
everybody knows i'm getting a divorce
fate is real you're working at the same
school as your first love you've been
through a lot my life sucks pretty bad
too 50 bucks says that my life sucks
more than yours you're on
that's a dollar
i see that money money money money
bayside hasn't won the spirit
competition for 200 years if we don't
learn from the past we are doomed to
repeat it that's why we have all these
reboots of teen shows from the 90s
get a new idea hollywood
year i came to the school knowing
exactly who i was and now i have no idea
nobody knows who they are in high school
i call this meeting to order thank you
all for being here on a wednesday you
know the school everyone's day right on
hump day
yes
[Music]
you